what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and if you haven't seen
spider-man knowing home and have somehow
managed to avoid spoilers here is your
spoiler warning because we're going to
get into some specifically
about daredevil charlie cox's return
playing the character matt murdock aka
daredevil and spider-man no way home was
amazing but it looks like he is not done
it looks like he's sticking around in
the mcu for a little bit and it looks
like he's getting his own disney plus
show now we know that the marvel netflix
series are about to come to disney plus
in just a few days now so all of this
timing is a little bit coincidental a
little bit too coincidental but today
we're going to talk about what projects
daredevil could appear in plus talk
about him getting his own series and
talk about the other defenders could
they be making an entrance into the mcu
like jessica jones luke cage iron fist
the punisher we're gonna talk about all
that then talk a little bit about what
to expect from disney plus investor day
which is tomorrow where hopefully we'll
be getting some news about some upcoming
movies and shows and of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos now i know a
lot of people were hoping when they saw
daredevil in spider-man no way home or i
should say when they saw matt murdock
and spider-man noe-home that it wasn't
just going to be one quick cameo in the
mcu and that's it he's done he's out
we'll never see him again and for those
people hoping that we have good news it
looks like not only is daredevil going
to be sticking around in the mcu but he
could be playing a major part in the mcu
and could even go on to be an avenger
and i'll talk about all of the possible
upcoming projects i think he's going to
be in but first let's talk about the
possibility of daredevil getting his own
show according to murphy's
multiverse.com a new production company
was formed less than two weeks ago
titled blind faith productions llc now
the speculation and educated guess is
that this more than likely belongs to
marvel studios this is their company
that they registered for a daredevil
project blind faith production seems to
be a clever play on one the fact that
matt murdock is literally blind and two
his catholicism in the comics now it is
worth noting that although this is very
very likely a daredevil project
especially if you consider the fact that
daredevil is now in the mcu disney has
not confirmed a daredevil project is in
the works in fact when people reached
out to disney apparently they denied
this but let's talk about why this
actually makes perfect sense daredevil
is a huge fan favorite character you can
find tons of audience reactions to matt
murdock in spider-man knowing home
online where people are just freaking
out people love daredevil so it would
make sense that they wouldn't bring him
back for just a quick little cameo plus
think about everything that is coming up
from disney plus specifically two shows
she hulk and the echo series that is
coming now matt murdock is a lawyer in
new york jennifer walters is a lawyer in
new york it would make a ton of sense
for daredevil matt murdock to appear in
the she-hulk series whether they're
friends or whether they're colleagues or
acquaintances or maybe perhaps they're
going to trial against each other at
some point in time it would just make
sense that two superhero lawyers that
both live in new york would come in
contact with each other now of course
matt murdock will know that jennifer
walters is a she-hulk but she more than
likely won't know that matt murdock is
daredevil but i'm expecting at least one
quick cameo like we saw matt murdock do
in spider-man knowing home in she-hulk
rumors have it that he could appear in
more than one episode right now but
we'll have to wait and see on that
however something that makes even more
sense is matt murdock appearing in the
echo series and when i say appearing i
don't just mean for a quick little cameo
but in multiple episodes why well one in
the comics ekko is his lover and two we
know that kingpin is going to be the
villain of the echo series and for those
of you who are thinking that kingpin
died at the end of the hawkeye series
because ekko shot him in the face this
actually happens in the comics as well
and kingpin comes back he gets blind in
both eyes which is kind of ironic
because he's the enemy of daredevil but
eventually he regains his sight and
returns as the villain which is what we
are all assuming is going to happen in
the echo series which is another huge
reason that it makes sense for daredevil
to appear kingpin is the ultimate
daredevil villain so hopefully we get a
romantic relationship between matt
murdock and echo in this show although
they have definitely changed the origin
of the story a little bit and hopefully
we get a daredevil vs kingpin fight
eventually i don't think this will
happen in the echo series but i'm
thinking if there is indeed a daredevil
show in development that's when it
probably will happen plus not to mention
a lot of people really really really
want a daredevil spider-man team up we
kind of got a little tease in spider-man
knowing home but we want the real thing
daredevil all suited up fighting with
spider-man and if we get a daredevil
series there's always a chance that this
could happen in the series as well and
if this does happen that means that
daredevil is going to have multiple mcu
appearances which leads me to believe
that marvel actually has some pretty big
plans for him and they want him to be a
prominent character in the mcu after all
we do need a new avengers team and this
is kind of the phase where they build
that team and you have to wonder since
they brought back charlie cox's matt
murdock slash daredevil and d'onofrio's
kingpin are they going to be bringing
anybody else back from the marvel
netflix series the marvel netflix shows
are coming to disney plus this month
marvel and disney have the rights to
these characters now and they've already
kind of rebooted two of them do they
have plans to do this for other
characters such as the punisher i
mentioned the punisher because it does
seem like marvel has started their kind
of darker side of the mcu right now moon
knight multiverse of madness blade the
werewolf by night special that is coming
hopefully ghost rider somewhere down the
line as well the punisher makes perfect
sense to bring into the mcu to join sort
of this supernatural more darker side of
the mcu and fans love jon bernthal as
the punisher and it does appear that
marvel and disney actually do kind of
take into consideration what the fans
think because we got charlie cox back as
matt murdock and dinafria back as
kingpin this proves that it's definitely
a possibility that jon could return to
play the punisher at some point in time
in the mcu as well as the rest of the
defenders i don't think they're all
going to return but i do think it's a
possibility that a few more could be
coming so big news looks like daredevil
is going to be a pretty prominent
character in the mcu if all of this
turns out to be true and perhaps we can
get a little bit of more info tomorrow
at disney's investors day tomorrow is
the 2022 annual meeting of the
shareholders and each year so far they
have kind of given us a little bit of a
tease of some projects coming up we're
not exactly sure what to expect because
it's different every year but we could
be getting some new trailer for some new
show i would not expect that thor love
and thunder trailer although there is a
chance it's possible but we'll most
likely get a look at she-hulk and miss
marvel but they also could reveal some
new series remember what this is for is
really to try to convince people to
invest and to also please their current
shareholders so they have to be kind of
impressive and kind of give a little
demonstration on what's coming up now
this isn't like disney plus day where
they reveal just a ton of things and
marvel gets you know a 30 minute slot
it's not like that but hopefully it will
be beneficial to us marvel fans and
hopefully they give us a little bit of a
tease for some upcoming projects that we
didn't know about so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
because i will be covering it tomorrow
and doing a video on whatever they
reveal so see you here tomorrow we'll
break everything down don't forget to
like this video and if you want live
updates throughout the investor meeting
be sure to follow me on twitter and
instagram as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you